字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Akinori Oyama
僕がこの場でスピーカーとして
話をさせていただくことは
とても光栄です
なぜならば
僕の人生の中で
初めて夢破れた場所だからです
というのは
僕が中学校三年生のとき
両親に初めて
正座をしてお願いをしました
「高校は
京都外大付属西高校にいき
京都外大に行きたい」と
そして
「京都外大に行き
海外にいきたい」と
中学二年のときアメリカに
ホームステイした経験もあり
海外に行きたかったのです
両親の返事は
想像もつかないものでした
どんな返事だと思いますか？
「そんなことより
早くお風呂に入りなさい」
(笑)
(拍手)
ここに来ている方々に
僕から一つお願いがあります
あなたに子供ができたとき
どうか子供の夢を
お風呂で片付けないでください
(笑)
その時のことは
今も鮮明に残っていて
だけで まさか その時は
この場所で
話をすることになるとは
思ってもみませんでした
今 僕は34歳で
お寿司の仕事に携わって
17年目です
ということは人生の半分
お寿司と共に過ごしている
という計算になります
そこで 分かってきたことは
お寿司には可能性が
沢山つまっているということです
これは何をしているところか
分かりますか？
歌舞伎役者が
化粧をしているところです
歌舞伎とお寿司
僕は日本の伝統芸能と
食を組み合わせることにより
日本の様々な素晴らしい文化を
世界に伝えていきたいと思います
そこで お寿司に
日本文化を伝える
可能性はないかと考え
書家
芸者
三味線
歌舞伎
和太鼓
落語 狂言などと
お寿司のコラボレーションを
行ってきました
芸術 食と別々の形で
日本の良さや
素晴らしさを発信するのではなく
食と文化の融合という
新しい形で
日本の良さを
伝えていきたいと考えています
さて 人間は何かを
記憶に残すとき
食 を交えると
脳裏に鮮明かつ斬新に
記憶に残るのではと考えます
そんな思いから 僕は常に
そこにスポットを当てて挑戦してきました
職人はただ単に
お客様の好むお寿司を握り
それを出すというのではなく
寿司は五感に訴えることができる
食の提供ができる
可能性を秘めている
ということが分かったのです
五感とはまず視覚
視覚で訴える寿司
それは正にアートです
寿司の美しさを
私は視覚的に訴えたい
そして 聴覚
(エビを揚げる音)
音は聴覚を刺激します
そして 食欲を沸き立てます
そろそろ お腹が
空いてきた頃でしょうか
そして 触覚
寿司を持ったときの感覚
それは壊れそうなものを
そっと手に取るような感覚で
それを口に運ぶまでの間
全神経が手や指に
集まるような感覚です
あなたはそんな経験がありますか？
そして 味覚
素材の甘味
酢飯の酸味
わさびの辛み
お寿司を塩で食べ
お茶の渋さを味わう
寿司は味覚の全てを
一度に堪能することができます
そして それが寿司の
醍醐味でもあります
その味覚の
バランスの良さがあるからこそ
全く異なった分野の
食材や素材と
融合できる可能性を
秘めているのかも知れません
最後に嗅覚
酢や魚 素材の匂い
嗅覚は想像力をかき立てます
人の想像力は多岐に渡り
嗅覚は食への
満足感 期待感を高めます
そして それが本当に
美味しい寿司であったとき
人々は満足感に溢れ
とても幸せな気持ちになります
食も文化も五感を
刺激するものであり
出会うべくして
出会っているのです
そして 共存と融合という
新しい形を経て
世界へと発信されていくのです
(ビデオ)
昔 あるお客様が言いました
「お寿司に合う
ワインは何ですか？」
そして職人はこう答えます
「お寿司に合う
ワインなんてない」
今となっては
少なくはなりましたが
いわゆる 昔ながらの職人は
実際にそう答える人が
多いと思います
お寿司に合うワインなんてない
果たして本当に
そうなのでしょうか？
お寿司に合うワインを出す
ワインに合ったお寿司を出す
そこには大きな違いがあります
それは 主役の違い
昔ながらの職人は
お寿司だけを主役に考えます
お寿司ありきの
飲み物という考え方です
僕はまずワインを飲み
想像します
喉を通り 体に入っていくワインに
イメージを膨らませ
そのワインにあう
最高のお寿司を創ります
これは単に
お客様の好むお寿司を握り
それを出すというのではなく
口にする全てのものが
主役となるもの
「ワインを飲みながら
お寿司を食べたい」
というお客様の気持ちを
お寿司に込め
両方が主役となるものを創る
そうして 初めて
最高のお寿司を
演出することができるのです
様々な食材が手に入り
流通が非常によくなった
この時代に
お寿司のネタをこれまでの形に
囚われることなく
変えていくことが
重要であると考えます
お寿司のネタはこれからも
どんどん変わっていくでしょう
それに 即座に対応出来る
技術と柔軟な頭
そして 新しいものを
取り入れることに対する
冒険心と経験が必要である
と僕は考えます
例えば
エビと
マスカルポーネチーズの握り
ワインビネガーで作られたシャリ
イクラとブルーチーズの握り
マカロンやクッキーも
お寿司になり得ます
チョコレートや
アイスクリームにあう
お寿司があっても
よくありませんか？
それほど お寿司には
未知なる可能性が
秘められているのです
これまでのお寿司の概念
固定観念を外してみたとき
そこにある無限の可能性に
僕は魅了されています
革新的なお寿司を
創造していく一方で
残していかなければならない
伝統もあります
その一つであるのが修行
修行は長く
とても辛い道のりですが
修行をすることにより
お寿司に対する情熱
道具や器 素材への
理解や想いが生まれます
修行という厳しい世界があるのは
日本ならではのことであり
伝統の一つとして
残されていくものでしょう
また 今後お寿司が
どんなに変化したとしても
日本の伝統や文化
そして 美しさは
継承していかなければなりません
進化し続けるお寿司
例えば海苔
日本の伝統的な柄である
江戸小紋の柄を施して
太巻きに
郷土料理の押し寿司も
こんな風に
こちらはちらし寿司の
ウエディングケーキ
ウニは軍艦巻ではなく
握りで出す
海苔とウニが
喧嘩しないことを考えたり
米粒一つで
(笑)
世界一小さいお寿司も
僕はこれからも
お寿司を通じて
世界へ日本文化を
伝えにいく旅を続けたい
そして 世界に出て行くことにより
他国の文化を受け入れ
お寿司を進化させたいと思います
お寿司に秘められた
可能性は無限です
その 可能性や価値を
生み出してくれる食材
日本の伝統や
世界中の様々な文化と
共に冒険し続ける
そして 秘められた価値に
光を当て
形にし 届けたい
人々はまだまだ
秘められたお寿司の
可能性や魅力に気づけていない
新鮮な魚を食すだけでなく
手間暇かけた芸術と
技術の結晶を
一瞬で堪能する
その儚さや 瞬間 刹那こそが
お寿司の美学であり
最高の贅沢だと考えます
日本という豊かな国に生まれ
こんにち 寿司職人で
いられることは本当に幸せです
様々なものと融合し
日本 そして世界へ
チャレンジし続ける
そして 秘められた可能性に
光を当て 形にし
世界中の人に届ける旅を
続けていきたいと思います
どうもありがとうございました
(拍手)